[Música]
donde hablamos y analizamos los 11 años
tras el inicio de la revolución en libia
que terminó en la caída y muerte de
muamar al gadafi el levantamiento se
convirtió rápidamente en una guerra
civil con el surgimiento de milicias lo
que dejó a la nación dividida entre
oriente y occidente y en manos de estos
grupos armados de los cuales algunos aún
se niegan a entregar las armas el
resultado de 11 años de guerra es un
estado fallido con cientos de miles de
desplazados asesinatos y violaciones en
masa cometidos por todos los frentes
entonces para analizar lo que pasa en
ese país quiero saludar a haizam amirah
fernández e investigador principal del
mediterráneo y mundo árabe de real
instituto elcano en madrid' gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france a 24 y le pregunto entonces 11
años después de la revolución en libia y
la caída de muammar al-gaddafi cuál es
la situación actual del país cuál es el
balance que podemos dar
bueno el balance de lo ocurrido en libia
en 11 años es muy sombrío es un estado
que como tal tampoco existía durante los
más de 40 años de régimen autoritario de
muamar gadafi prácticamente cumplió los
41 años en el poder absoluto y con un
estilo de gobernar de propio de un
megalómano
sin embargo nada de lo que ha ocurrido
en estos últimos 11 años era inevitable
la población libia no está condenada a
vivir en estado de caos de violencia el
problema ha sido la herencia de esas
cuatro décadas de un régimen totalitario
absolutista personalista y además
también la ausencia de unos líderes
internos los líderes locales políticos
sociales y comunitarios que hayan
trabajado para crear una
un estado y una nación y además hay que
añadir a eso la injerencia que se ha
ejercido desde el exterior desde países
vecinos desde potencias regionales
potencias internacionales
motivadas principalmente por los grandes
recursos de hidrocarburos de petróleo
que tiene libia y eso ha propiciado pues
tanto alimentar la guerra y los bandos
enfrentados entre sí como mantener una
economía de guerra donde se benefician
aquellos que están al mando de los
bandos y de las milicias y de los
diferentes gobiernos diferentes
parlamentos hay dos de ellos en el país
y esto es lo que está impidiendo que
libia se convierta a día de hoy en un
estado que funcione que vaya teniendo un
papel constructivo en su entorno norte
africano y mediterráneo haizam y por eso
le quería preguntar entonces de cómo se
encuentran estas fuerzas políticas
dentro de libia como están conformados y
cómo hacer para salir de esta crisis
social y política y poder tener un solo
gobierno para poder digamos a
implementar medidas efectivas dentro del
país para poder ir mejorando la
situación sobre todo los de los civiles
de los ciudadanos que son los
principales afectados
así es en libia y problema de
legitimidad es un choque de
legitimidades donde no hay un proceso
claro establecido ha acordado con unas
reglas de cómo se accede al poder cuáles
son los mecanismos
de cuál es una constitución que
establezca precisamente estas reglas del
juego político y en ausencia de esos
mecanismos de resolución de conflictos
internos y de creación de estructuras
fatales de creación también de una
cultura democrática de una cultura
participativa por parte de la población
como eso no existe lo que hay que es el
recurso a la fuerza
y a maniobras para intentar
imponerse frente a los demás rivales
políticos considerados muchas veces como
enemigos existenciales y a eso ha
contribuido
el apoyo desde el exterior a los bandos
enfrentados- mediante las armas que
llegan en enormes cantidades a ese país
a pesar del embargo de armas dictado por
naciones unidas en 2011 y ahí están
países vecinos de la región pero también
países del golfo pérsico que están
apoyando a distintos bandos también
desde turquía desde rusia es decir desde
fuera se está impidiendo que la
población libia pueda vivir con todo
aquello que anhelo y con las reformas
que consideraron necesarias cuando se
levantaron contra el dictador gadafi y
estos 11 años han sido 11 años perdidos
para la población de libia donde ha
habido violencia donde ha habido
derramamiento de sangre donde se ha
evitado construir un estado que es lo
que hace falta tanto para los libios y
las libias como también para el norte de
áfrica y para el conjunto del
mediterráneo que está sometido a crisis
conflictos y dificultades que han vez
sido grabadas por la pandemia de kobe 19
ahora haizam que se espera entonces para
este proceso de transición que además
según dicen el gobierno reconocido por
ramón o el líder de ese gobierno se va a
quedar en el poder de libia hasta
posiblemente unas elecciones en julio
qué tan probable es que se dé esta
transición que tan probable es que se
den esas elecciones en el mes de junio
para que sean unas elecciones
medianamente pues libres y democráticas
y había elecciones previstas para
finales de diciembre pasado no tuvieron
lugar y esto es lo que está haciendo es
prolongar un periodo de interinidad
donde sigue sin aclararse
cuál es la legitimidad o cómo se accede
al poder por la vía legítima hay
dificultades tanto en el marco legal
como cómo se organizan las elecciones
como se supervisan quién se puede
presentar a las mismas hay también un
problema de los liderazgos
fracturados que no solamente porque haya
dos parlamentos incluso ahora mismo
parece que incluso hay dos primeros
ministros en libia sino también porque
dentro de lo que parecería un bando
cuestionado en el este del país
o en el oeste
también hay fracturas internas y también
todo esto está
condicionado por las milicias armadas
que imponen su voluntad de mediante la
intimidación y todo eso con una economía
de guerra
donde hay paradojas muy sorprendentes
como que sea y los recursos del estado
libio quien financia a las milicias de
ambos bandos por los acuerdos que tienen
entre ellos con lo cual esto al final si
desde el exterior no se ayuda a la
población libia y a sus representantes
oa sus poderes fácticos si desde el
estricto exterior se sigue alimentando
el enfrentamiento la economía de guerra
las elecciones no parece probable que
vayan a celebrarse en un futuro cercano
sino que van a seguir maniobrando los
distintos actores en libia con el apoyo
del exterior para intentar tener
posiciones ventajosas aunque el coste
sea que las redes que surja un estado
viable en libia